احرق
يا سوري هذا الفيديو انا مسميه يوم البعث
هذا اليوم اللي انا شعرت
بانه هو ولادتي الحقيقيه اليوم اللي شعرت
بكياني
بوجودك انسان
بهاي الحياه
سوريا حره
سوريا
كبار شريحه السوريه
تصوير المظاهرات بالايام الاولى للثوره
كان شيء اشبه بالانتحار يعني اللي بيصور
بده يكون فدائي بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه يا
اما بده يموت يا اما بدي تم اعتقاله
الاعتقال طبعا كانت نهايته لعبد الله هو
كان مفكر اما الشهاده او الاعتقال اما له
خبر في طريق ثالث هو التهجير كمان
تهجرنا من داريا بعد حصار اربع سنين تهجير
قصري بدون خيار تاني اقتلعونا من داريا
واخذونا على مكان مجهول مع مصير مجهول وما
زال لهلا مجهول
الجيل اللي نشا للصغره الجيل المتمرد بقى
اجد انا ان التعليم هو المجال الاهم
والاول ثوريا
لتثبيت الثوره وتحقيق اهدافها مع الاسف
بسبب طول المعاناه اللي عاشوها السوريين
بسبب طول الثوره 12 سنه مده كبيره بانه
الناس اعتادت على الماساه اعتدت انه في
مصيبه بسوريا وقت بشوف اي حدا خبر عن
سوريا اكيد هدول عندهم مصيبه او مجزره او
بيت مهدم او عيله راحت انتقلنا للنقطه
اخطر بشوي هي موضوع انه النسيان انت مضطر
دائما انك تذكر الناس باللي صار بسوريا
مثلا فقره اربع من رفاق ضرب اللي كنا انا
واياهم مع بعض دائما 24 ساعه فقدت طراد
الزهور
فقد خالتي خالد العيسى بحلب رائد الفارس
وحمود جنيد بس لانه كانوا عم يحاولوا
يوصلوا صوت مختلف عن الاصوات اللي اللي
السماعه طبعا عبد الله هو يعني كان
تنسيقيه الثوره بمعرض النعمان
2012 تم اعتقاله فهل هو متوفي هل هن
محتفظين فيه يعني شعور كثير صعب يعني انت
بدك تصدق انا اذا ميت احسن لي ها كثير
كثير رح انبسط انه مات من 2014 وارتاح
بالتعذيب من الظلم من برد من الامراض من
الزلازل هلا مثل ما انا شايف ايش وضعهن
السجناء بالابوات النظام تهجير بالنسبه
لنا انه مو بس انه نحن طلعنا من بيت او
طلعنا من ارض وخسرنا
هالبيت المكون من جدران وارض
نحن كنا ببيت بيت اهلي
ست شباب
يوميا الكل يجي على البيت المسا ولو نسلم
على بعض ويرجع كل واحد يروح على بيته
يعني هذا البيت هو
كان بالنسبه لنا مصدر سعاده مصدر امل مصدر
تفاؤل
عشنا كلنا فيه ربينا فيه
[موسيقى]
خسرنا هاي الذكريات خسرنا هاي اللمه
بدهم يسالوك انه عندك امل انه نظام الاسد
يسقط ما هو سقط سقط من اول صرخه حريه ولم
تنجح جميع محاولات الانظمه العربيه اللي
هي تتشابه معه الى حد ما
واعاده تعويمه مطلبنا الاساسي كان من
بدايه الثوره وما زال هو اسقاط النظام ولو
انه النظام سقط من بدايه الثوره كان وفر
علينا قتل وتدمير وتهجير وكان في مستقبل
احلى لسوريا